welcome to keeps my gameplay episode 62
i am your host Kevin Van Orden this week
is very special because we're unscripted
we've had a very very busy week and so I
do not have any quizzes or games lined
up we're just gonna sit down for maybe
30 45 minutes and talk about stuff and
then we're going to say goodbye so it's
very it's very non-traditional gamespot
gameplay this particular week so i would
like to introduce everybody at the table
and we're gonna start across from me
just to switch things up uh Justin a
walled is back hey hey hey how's it go
it's gone pretty good how's news this
week oh it's been very newsy it is
breaking me constantly it is a break
like waves and what a notion is that hey
hey what you want us to call like is
that a new nickname for you J hey J hey
J hey shut with Justin this news Justin
J hey meanwhile the options Cynthia
where's is she's your you're taking
selfies no I'm do you Wow oh okay look
what you were so like doing selfies
while I was doing the intro it's like so
I mean I love the green I love the green
hair but I don't know how do you do a
self my job you do a selfie photos to
all end up on facebook at some point yay
Cynthia what do you do for gamespot for
those that aren't used to seeing you on
the cake on the podcast I am gamespot's
community manager in social media
producer Wow so like all of the tweets
and Facebook posts and google+ things
and tumblers I I have a big hand in that
and vines oh that's how much vines oh
nothing would find no that's still
Francie oh oh does she's still helping
out yes yes Oh miss her so much and of
course you've already seen his face on
the podcast it's chris waters seat right
next to me everybody hi Kevin Hey hello
Justin that's India Thanks uh it's fun
it's been a fun week well a fun past
days have fun playing a lot of titanfall
yeah it's a fun busy week for all of us
oh and I forgot to introduce our special
guest I'll gross our special guest is
this can of diet barq's that has been
sits been here for three weeks now and
it's it's not an empty can it is
full can don't show them the crud around
the yard or gross amount it's getting
more and more delicious wiggins podcast
so this podcast brought my diet barq's I
guess uh they're not paying us anything
actually you can say that but it says
it's good so that must come for
something it says it's good right about
handling it be good has diseases yeah
you're gonna want to wash your hands now
I'll Gestapo you lick tips this is what
happens when you don't make quizzes
Kevin I I lick the old yeah diet barq's
little tastes like the muni so far I
guess all the people who are not litter
the titanfall beta has started yeah
people are in it yes I've gotten code we
were in it live for like four hours
yesterday Danny O'Dwyer and Sean and I
did a live stream and plates Oh much
titanfall beta NT phones quickly turned
into like what 64 it was just under 4
Sean McKenna's came back from playing
this in an event and he said this is
basically a reason to get an Xbox one do
you agree with that I it's not it's on
other platform it's on a PC is on pc
xbox one xbox 360 is what I'm I'm not
sure if I would go that far yet I mean
when we played the beta and it's it's a
limited slice of the game I would say
it's gonna make me happy that I've
already bought an xbox one cuz I have an
xbox one it's not yet it's getting a lot
of play into like Netflix and Hulu Plus
situations but uh game-wise not been
that active but now with titanfall beta
and titanfall coming out in like a few
short weeks I am very happy to have an
xbox one it's been a drought for
Microsoft exclusives for for quite a
while like well we have over 25 man come
on not need outside of the xbox one
launch before that last year for xbox
360 was pretty scarce as far as xbox
exclusive titles mm-hmm and this is this
is a huge coup especially for people
that they've got a playstation 4 and
which is doing really really well is
selling better than xbox one but almost
two to one so nice all week we've
transitioned out of titanfall already to
another subject that was it just flows
it's those are it's a river of
information happens tenfold come back uh
yes so the open beta it's happening or
it's not an open beta it's closed beta
you can like register for codes on
titanfall com you can get some and
giveaways we've been giving some away
and I think we have more to give away
today you're actually we're gonna be
giving away codes today at 6pm on
twitter and then tomorrow on twitter and
then sunday on twitter and then monday
on twitter at same time but no 60 right
okay different times okay special
mystery time of course we say six pm
that specific just in case people are in
different places and yes pretty much
assume that not Hawaii games vodka but
so it's uh it's so it's just call of
duty with robots and parkour know yup
nailed it next up what makes this fun or
special or so so it's what make the park
or makes it a lot of fun for one egg for
one possibility it the possibilities
says Benito chiming in from behind the
production desk over there it's the
speed of game of play is similar to call
of duty uh that having the Titans in
play is is not is very dissimilar from
called avi then but then you've got the
parkour which is not really similar to
anything I mean like brink tried some
parkour based stuff and did not end up
doing it so well Kevin you end up
playing a bit of that again yeah so but
this it's guy once you get a match or
two hundred your belt it's very fluid in
terms of running along walls jumping up
walls maneuvering around the battlefield
with this kind of verticality I feel
like verticality is a kind of a buzzword
in multiplayer shooters where you've
designed these maps to have verticality
so you need to like you know a climb or
take a vehicle up or be aware of a
battlefield on more than just this kind
of plane but titanfall does it in a way
it's way better then that's way more
natural and integrated than these other
than other games have tried to do it
because it is so easy to get up high um
I just doesn't mean it's always good to
just get up high like it's not like
everyone races to the top and then it's
all good that's the thing right it's
like there's more of the ways than the
stairs to get upstairs there are there
are a lot more ways although sometimes
taking the stairs is good because people
don't expect you to I was kind of
surprised that there wasn't a dominant
way to play there's not like there's a
distinct advantage to being in a robot
or there's a distinct advantage to being
on foot like people have a depending on
your play style like one of those is
like what you might enjoy more than the
others what is ending on where the
matches and the ebb and flow of the
match and what kind of objective you're
trying to accomplish at one time like
I've definitely played matches where I
have my Titan available but I'm not
calling it in just because I'm on a roll
as a pilot and I'm enjoying that
free-flowing freewheeling stuff in
Daniel Dwyer was outgoing the same
sentiment on our live stream yesterday
it is fun to play as both you do feel
powerful and effective as both and I
mean there's a lot of talk about you
know multiplayer game has to be balanced
right you have to have these different
elements all imbalance balanced in some
way and so far so good for titanfall
with balance thing here's something that
came up that Kara was describing to me
now I haven't actually played titanfall
I just got a beta key today but I'll be
okay see [ __ ] so okay your your xbox
one stuff is serious but seriously like
she was describing the the bit where cuz
cuz when you Luke cuz you lose and you
have like a dropship come to get you at
the end right now and at that point
you've lost there is no rescuing at that
point and so what I said to her as well
that makes it sound like suddenly every
man for himself and herself at the very
end of the match because there's no
there's no winning for the team at this
stage I'm really cure I think this is
actually a really interesting dynamic
because when when there's no longer a
team benefit to working together once
you've lost you've lost but you can
still personally get you know get some
experience out of it if you get into the
dropship for it I'm really curious about
this idea cuz I said to her well that
means that there's no reason to play as
a team anymore she's like I don't know I
think you'll probably want to play as a
team and get as many people back to the
dropships again and I'd be like forget
that I'm getting to the dropship fu all
kind of sewing I'm curious yes a little
bit not a not a great team player
there's an art show you're gonna run
colors my point being like I'm curious
to see when a game takes away the value
of B of working together as a team yeah
I'm curious to know how that changes
player behavior in that particular
instance like what obviously reveals you
to be
complete [ __ ] well Ashley I mean
that's not necessarily the way I play
but I'm saying the first thing I thought
of is everybody is going to be running
like in and who cares about getting
everybody else like but is this an
opportunity for you to show your color
like your true colors by either
forgetting everybody else are being like
this I got your man I might go down but
I'll help you live first off I think you
might be overestimating amount of team
cohesiveness that there existed before
that epilogue state where you're just
trying to race I do think you do get
multiplied experience bonuses for having
more teammates escaping the dropship
though ok I have only ever escaped solo
and only ever escaped like twice so I
don't have a huge sample size to draw
from um but the thing is like the game
you've lost and it'll say it all say
defeated or it'll say victory and so you
part of you would kind of imagine like
all right yeah like we could just go
shoo whoever doesn't matter or like all
right fine i'm gonna try to make this a
dropship but doesn't matter but it does
matter like you do care you don't just
flip the switch of caring how you do or
at least for me I don't flip the switch
of caring how I am in the game just
because my team has won or my team has
lost if anything it like dedicates me
more well now that might be overstating
it but I the new objective is something
to get excited about and if you are with
your team your art you know you're gonna
be able to not get picked off where
you're going to be able to bring down
that drop ship with your barrage of
Titan fire a little more so I don't it's
interesting you had that reaction though
because it I guess you know it does sort
of the in some way dissolve the bonds of
team teamwork are you ready so do you
like the epilogue I do like the epilogue
I I feel like there are times when I
just get shot pretty quick and then I
have to watch other people doing
whatever and then I don't care to watch
and there are other times where and it
doesn't it isn't always the like
exciting nail-biting escape that you
imagined it to be right but sometimes it
is and then that's really fun but then
if I'm on the winning team I'm thinking
about what is it like to be on the
winning team when the losing team gets
you know the dropship comes and and cuz
get that point then you're
you're shooting down people I mean
obviously they're just going to get out
of that it but you're shooting people
down more for the hell of it you've
gotten your win at this stage it's
almost like playing with your victim yes
and insult to injury yeah it's at all
that's like the best part no I don't
give victory and there's that loud chime
and you just go and you start mowing
people down that's the best part I mean
I do that multiplayer shooters anyway
like when like sometimes you can still
get it like you can still shoot a few
people down after the victory comes and
before you wait for the next match
before like everybody freezes and in
killzone or something yeah like him kill
zone or something you may still like
shoot shoot somebody down before so yeah
feel free you're gonna love it so but I
don't know like I I think it's a really
interesting dynamic and I and I I'm
curious to see if it actually does
changing I mean this is all from just
merely a an intellectual point of view I
haven't played yet but I think about
that and I think about the way that can
sort of stimulate or kind of affect how
you feel and it's kind of interesting to
be stimulated in that way intellectually
by of first-person shooter yes last time
that came along well not often but I
mean it's a different kind of it's a
different kind of thing like you don't
want multiplayer shooters expecting to
be really breaking this stuff down I
mean thing I think they're actually very
few multiplayer shooters that lend
themselves to any kind of talk about I
mean I think actually call of duty does
like to a certain extent because you can
talk about the weight you know is it
good that it rewards you for playing
badly is it good that it you know that
kind of thing like that kind of stuff
can come up but it's you know usually
multiplayer shooters is like it's like
whatever but this this is actually a
really interesting dynamic and I'm
curious to explore it my favorite part
of Call of Duty really is the discourse
that you get with other players and and
I'm curious how that plays out in
titanfall do you get called things that
i could probably can't say on the radio
right so the radio yeah it's not it's
not so mull of the sample size of people
in there is not super large and
yesterday i mean most bulk of my time
playing the beta has been on that was on
that live stream so i wasn't listening
to anyone doing any headset chat i was
listening to Danny and looking at the
Chad and stuff like that so I jury's
still out it exists oh I'm sure it does
so no what you didn't hear a lot of suck
my Richard you bundle of sticks no not
nothing so playfully worded I'm afraid
well cuz I mean like right now it's like
other reviewers or other other people in
the in Italy gave you a certain extent
but there's also they've now sent out
like random to people like yesterday it
was you could only do it if EA send you
a code early which like we saw people
from other you know sites um yeah we saw
some IGN players I think we saw some
maybe some polygons players uh I know
that Walter was super excited to come
down um people from depth came over Greg
yeah yeah he was in one of the matches
we played it was fun that's what yanked
him out of a mech he was a ah as an
aside like actually sometimes when you
review a multiplayer game in advance of
everybody else having it you're playing
against other journalists that's one of
my favorite things especially when Jim
sterling shows up in a multiplayer match
which he always does for killzone
because he always reviews Killzone I
always really kills on so we always end
up like shooting each other down which
is kind of fun oh yeah but anyway added
me to detailing Adam Sessler with an EOD
bot in battlefield 4 during the review
event was really enjoy yeah uh EA has
gotten so much [ __ ] for their online
service system battlefield 4 was a mess
for months SimCity launched to a
complete failure of horribleness yeah
dude how is the stacking up does it seem
like this is gonna be okay I don't know
I don't know just over eight okay yeah
you've got you got max 12 players in a
match uh they've got the beta ahead of
time but battle feel how to beta at a
time I mean did that do what I can't
remember now like looking back what was
the battlefield 4 beta good like was
there any inkling of the horrendous
problems the austere [ __ ] that was gonna
happen 0 because a big deal of a big
part of that uh battlefield 4 beta was
that like I noticed that the graphics
improved exponentially when the ladies
came out so there was a lot of stuff
that was an innovative yes assuming the
same way with that there was yeah all
through world stuff that I can remember
seeing like videos of like oh look at me
I'm underneath bounds I'm going to shoot
up at people awake so there's still the
potential for horrible horrible failure
there is also from that that tough
question i was just talking with john
carlo about today you know like if they
are gonna have you know a review event
that's going to be ahead of time
this is a question we always encounter
Kevin is level every time you get you
know if our only opportunity to play the
game ahead of time is at a review event
but that's also in very controlled
circumstances you know that a review
that comes out of that circumstance
certainly has value about the content of
the game but then once it's released to
retail servers you know how does that
how does the value chip proposition
change when and how does the review
change if they run into problems and so
that's something we're definitely taking
a real hard look at for titanfall yeah
release is how we handle that and how we
keep you guys updated on it and and
review events you also get the huge
money hat as everybody else where I mean
every day you drive in in that
Lamborghini of yours and that's sweet
sweet EA money everything's everything's
better when you're wearing a money hat I
mean it just sits on your head it's
light yet comforting and it just makes
you feel really secure and a little bit
dashing I like when Sony and Microsoft
have contributed to my money suit I'm
not wearing it today but you know it's
hundred dollar bills yeah all I never
managed is a money jockstrap Wow we took
it there I'm wearing it right now I mean
worth that's because of your RIT your
rider whenever you agree to these
contracts to review games is must
include money Jacques you need you need
to stop with this subject cuz people are
actually gonna take it seriously I can
see it now musically kotaku puts up
something like gamespot admits to money
hat is not wearing multiple items made
clothing items made of money Cynthia
what money garb do you get community
doesn't get money come on should sail
money towards know there's well cuz we
have we have to make it we have to
listen to people complain to us we
listen to people talk about how you guys
are all wearing money had some money oh
yeah they never say that right to us
that was the thing that the people said
about battlefield 4 is like oh you guys
got all guys got paid off by EA and
that's why you gave it such good reviews
even though it was such a [ __ ]
experience when it came out but it was
because we reviewed it under wonderful
circumstances that did not happen to
play out in real what was that and then
also after reviewing like when I
reviewed it for the platform's we didn't
get to play ahead of time and I
definitely announced as I played it on
the platforms like I did not experience
nearly as many issues as
vocal minority the majority minority I
don't know there were clearly issues and
they persisted for a while but in terms
of my own player experience those issues
were not nearly as frequent as you would
hear about if you read the comments of a
battlefield 4 stories so that puts us in
a tough position right I mean for every
person that comments up I had five
server crashes last night that how many
people are having a perfect night of
playing battlefield 4 those people
aren't commenting an equal measure and
so it's kind of tough to get a bead on
those things sometimes and so you know I
think that you know we you know the news
team certainly covered a lot of the
battlefield 4 fiasco at from a review
standpoint we didn't really delve too
much into it here and I think going
forward with titanfall we're definitely
taken yeah you know taking that to heart
and trying to try to talk amongst
ourselves about better about ways to
handle it it is more you know there is
more reactive to that situation we
always want to try to find this place
where I mean obviously you want to get
it right the first time right but on the
other hand we also want to have
something up for people when they when
they come and the truth is like until
until everybody has that game and the
servers are switched on for every single
person you just never know it's going to
be a little bit of a crapshoot but on
the other hand you know a review can at
least handle the the content of that
game and so on and so forth so it's
always you know how do we how do we do
this so that we don't turn it into I
mean because as much as we love polygon
on the other hand we don't want to run
into situations where it's like we're
changing the score every day because
that's also not actually doing people
any good either so you just have a
Twitter so the review is just your
twitter feed and it's constantly updated
you can only do it in 140 increments and
it's score might change day to day based
on your Twitter updates based on how
many tweets we do a day yeah I mean
score it would be great to get rid of
scores but it's like I honestly I love
scores I think love them I think scores
are interesting and from one perspective
I'd love to get rid of them because I
want people to read the thing I wrote
right and like here and see the content
and get the value from that the other
but there are problems associated with a
with that number one is without a score
I don't think people would be reading it
as much and number two is I think we we
have helped create the monster that
scores
have I just go to metod I go to Rotten
Tomatoes and I like to see like what did
what did everyone say and I'll read the
little blurb and I'll see their score
and if their blurb convinced me to read
it then maybe I'll go to the whole
review what was really interesting
because though because sometimes even
then you know the score can be a
hindrance in another way so this moves
us on actually to final fantasy because
so final fantasy got a very very mixed
reaction from the critical mass in
general I think Metacritic was at 68
yesterday or something when I looked at
it so it's been but there have been you
know higher scores in mine and lower
scores in mind your score being a 5 yeah
I gave it a 5 out of 10 and which in the
video game rating scale is basically
zero but I think I mean on our scale it
means mediocre and I think yeah the game
is mediocre I think it's got some bright
spots and some reasons to play and I
also think it's problematic and
troublesome and we'll talk Chris and
I'll talk a little about this because
he's been playing too and I it this is
interesting because because chris has a
very different point of view for me
having never played Chris has never
played a final fantasy game until
lightning returns what would never hold
on no never never ever played ever a
final fantasy game ever in your life
Chris never has no no not a final
fantasy game I mean I've watched my
brother play final fantasy 7 40 not
insignificant amount of time but other
than that I mean I you work it I don't
understand you work in video you work in
a video game office how can you never
know how many video games there are in
the world Justin hey Waldo Final Fantasy
300 do you know how many street fighter
games I've played none I don't
understand I mean it can happen because
I've you can play around the street
fighter but you can't play a round of
Final Fantasy you can't really play like
half an hour final fantasy and get an
idea for what it's like it's like you
need to commit you guess eight days
straight tactics which episode there was
it you can like take breaks nearly
crisis core or you could play one of the
early games when have some random
battles and then call it it I've
occasionally been tempted to play final
fantasy games I've occasionally had the
opportunity to play final fantasy games
on systems that I don't know my just
have not been compelled I haven't felt
the desire to not say I haven't played
JRPGs you played chrono trigger right I
played Chrono Trigger earthbound
I have not played earthbound I don't
know you I played to completion eternal
sonata okay I like eternal sonata which
is like this you've never played Final
Fantasy 6 but you've played through
eternal sonata yeah which is a good game
is like a Final Fantasy 6 better Kevin's
Kevin's review was very convincing for
eternal sonata and so I went for I think
that games really and I really enjoyed
it uh but yet no it's my first final
fantasy endeavor which is a weird one to
choose right because it's uh the third
in a final it's in it the third in a
trilogy it's like starting a Star Wars
person on Episode two that doesn't make
sense episode 2 second no i mean like
episode 2 like saying oh never seen Star
Wars before I mean like okay cool watch
episode 2 whatever the heck that was
called Sidonie so where should I start
then fantasy one man sees don't all talk
to each other yeah all this yeah they
don't believe in this case these really
these three games tell and over have a
story arc these three games feature the
same care but the mechanics and
lightning returns are very difficult for
all different but on the other hand I
was curious to hear what well by the way
what I was gonna say before actually was
about scores too because I read um us
gamers review and that was who was that
Justin Jeremy Perrin Jeremy parish thank
you thank you I believe one up and it
was yes and I think Jeremy parish is
fantastic but it was an interesting
review because it was essentially you
know this game is kind of crap yet it
all comes together and 4 out of 5 stars
and that always gives you like the yeah
that always gets you to the point where
it's like I'm not quite sure how we got
from point A to point Z and that way so
that was that was a tough review for me
but a tip but it's it's interesting
because that game really has had ups
announcer Chris like I've now played
this game uh three times to a
masochistic degree times to compute like
real self-flagellating my first
playthrough I ran out of time and the
world just came to an end before I got
to the final boss the second time I come
on a new game plus I completed it the
third time I completed it with all but
maybe five of the side activities not
finished and some of the the optional
boss is not
beaten mm-hmm so now i'm actually going
in for the fourth round she said no the
losses each time so that i can yeah and
new things open up when you play again
but I'm I because I want to finish up
this boss guide and read read the boss
guide which is awesome sup um it's it's
almost completely of a guide there's
like ten not boxing most of the most of
the buses is all of the boss bosses in
the story all of the story bosses are
there nice and the other thing though
that it does is and this might be one of
the neatest things the game does
actually is it has extinction so if you
fight enough of a certain enemy it will
go extinct and the last one you fight is
called a last one and it's a real it's a
more powerful name up with that name I
know right it's a more idiom it's a more
powerful gonna bang crap it's a it's a
more powerful version of that same
monster and once you defeat it then
there are no you will no longer have
encounters with any monsters you have a
taxidermied version of that last one up
here in your like weird up in the arc
space Ark and the space Ark no no but
there is somehow a tree growing in that
goddamn arc how does that work Yggdrasil
lives in space duh in a in an arc army
do you know people so no Mary the soil
that's true it does live on souls but
it's weird because it doesn't die like
it only you just need it to bloom so
it's all very confusing what does but
you enjoy this looks JRPGs love you
yourself well so when I started into
this I was expecting to be thoroughly
baffled by the storyline done not just
because uh you know because our is
because the third in the trilogy but
also because uh you know I did not like
going in have like the greatest
impression of final fantasy story
telling in this apparently series as a
horror played one exactly and excused
from a place of pretty total ignorance
um but I found that like through a lot
of exposition which got to be a lot of
exposition I felt like pretty grounded
and was able to understand like where
I'm at who i am who what I'm trying to
do here
but then there's just so much talking
and so much redundant talking it's like
all right so like lightning your this
God has appointed you the Savior you
need to save everybody souls so that
they can live on in another world and
then lightning her reply is so you're
saying that I'm the Savior chosen by God
and I need to get people's souls so they
can live on in another world and it's
like it's one is conversations yeah I
learning a foreign language appointed
you this is the kind of repetition that
you see in learning like in language
learning courses where you repeat the
same concepts in different sentence
structures using the same vocabulary
words over and over again so that it's
drilled in your head your English has
gotten really good Thank You Justin
Kevin hasn't said anything about waiting
from the notice but like so I don't feel
disoriented at the same time I don't
understand why this is the third in a
trilogy because it seems like correct me
if I'm wrong all that other stuff having
500 years ago and this world now is like
only very loosely tied to the actions of
this and so like any time you meet
somebody who you knew before it's like
it feels almost like fan service which
is to say they're bringing them back for
the sake of you getting to see them
again not because the plot no that's a
man's there's a story that is unfinished
from before or anything like that so
normally a trilogy I you know I expect
there to be a lot more story momentum
coming in but it doesn't feel like there
is a whole lot of that in lightning no
they're all pretty it's it's interesting
because of course the same story threads
go through you know lightning you know
she was up in Valhalla and she's been up
there you know doing her thing and now
God sent her back to be the savior so on
and so forth and but you know final
fantasy 13 could have just ended and
that could have been in that could have
just been the end of things it didn't
need 13 to but then we got 13 to
regardless that's a good number 13 2 n's
more or less on uh you know a little bit
of a client you know uh you know what
cliffhanger yeah cliffhanger thank you
my God my brain doesn't function it only
took two times I know right so it is
cliff you know it ended on a cliffhanger
of sorts but then three doesn't really
follow through directly from that um it
ultimately get sort of resolved in the
way they handle Sarah but Sarah who was
one of the two main characters along
with Knoll in the second game is almost
never depicted in the game and yet they
talk about her all the time and that's
all that's all lightning is like the old
her only character trait is that she
misses Sarah she also has sexy sexy
costumes she does have sexy oh man
meeting articles they are so costumey I
my dress up is like alternately off
alternately makes are you putting up
magic like clearly magic right which I
guess exists in this world you would
magic it on and off its and switch
between it indica and it's fine lash of
battle I'm fine with some video game
lodge or like it's just really weird
though that like lightning will talk
about how she doesn't want to draw
attention to herself or something but
you're wearing that and I've and Chris
will stick you in a pirate hat or like a
feathered hat as a tricorn hat okay oh
it's green and it matches the straps
around her thighs and help out put her
in a goatee or a cat tail or something
and it's like this is gonna attract some
attention girl especially like I could
plunge my entire head down your cleavage
like this this this is the kind of thing
even people in this world would notice
girl but the battle stuff stood out to
me you you'd mentioned like you would be
stuck in battle so sometimes like half
an hour an hour and you could eat
potentially lose and then have to start
all of it like Rio 15 minutes in that
you're gonna lose but battles not
actually gonna end for 25 did you hit
that as well I know I watched him do
that I'm not that far in the game where
I have that kind of bow tie the timer
stops when you enter battle except in
one instance that that instance being a
an extra dungeon that you unlock if you
if you've completed a hundred plus side
quests
the final day um you add one you add a
thirteenth day and then you can get to
this dungeon that has all of the last
ones as separate bosses so you can
actually defeat the last ones without
actually making this species go extinct
but anyway that's the only place where
the clock doesn't stop or doesn't stop
during battle but the thing is if you
lose battle whether whether you escape
out of it or whether you lose and it
forces you to escape out of it you lose
an hour of time as time ticks forward
and that can be really frustrating um in
part because the game doesn't do a
really good job of preparing you
necessarily with what's coming it's
really weird because sometimes things
open up when you like when you complete
story quests things then open up like
side quests think people have will have
more things for you to do and so I got
in a habit of you know it's only for
large areas the game's not a big
expansive world or anything it's just
for pretty large regions you explore but
you so you end up going back over and
over again seeing if something new is
there and then you you you do and maybe
there's something there and that means
that you can get something out of it but
if you go back and something's not there
you've wasted with that time I'm and so
there's no I think when you have a time
limit like that you have to integrate it
somehow into the rest of the game but
all it does is like the rest of the game
just is what it is and then they just
stick this thing on top of it and I
guess that's what bothers me so much a
structure of the quests truck doesn't
seem to jive way well nothing well but
that's the whole game nothing jibes with
anything else did you end up enjoying
combat like I'm just on a pure challenge
of combat yeah cuz I'm kind of liking
that I think that I'm not getting into
that where it's it matters what you know
what my skin mod what my different
loadouts basically are the schemata and
you know like what how I'm trying to
stag our enemies and I'm starting to get
really into that and so I'm enjoying
that and it's the best part of the game
is the schemata and the tactical
implications of squamata but so I guess
my question is I don't know if you wanna
talk a little bit more about lightning
returns but for you guys who have played
Final Fantasy memes yes obviously your
indignation and may not have I had a
collector's edition for Final Fantasy
lightning returns waiting for me at home
are you excited about it
yes alright so what drop like what draws
you to final fantasy what have you
enjoyed in the past and what keeps you
coming back to the series ah sorry yeah
story story I part yet / using a rig of
world music exactly yeah final fantasy
13 was not my favorite just because it
felt felt very long and very plot it
felt like a really long tutorial to
actually get into it but the story in
the worlds that they create I love the
art of the world's I love the way that
they bring all of that together and I
think they just look like beautiful fun
games there's a lot of parts of this
game that are very pretty yeah and a lot
some a lot of the character models are
very you know attractive yes but also a
trap and in like a appealing interesting
kind of way I I like this that they lay
out or just neat yeah it the story stuff
still is I mean I guess I'm pretty early
in the game still it's not really
grabbing me like it only get one early
site where it's like lightning is gonna
do this thing because she that's for the
only way she's gonna save Sarah and like
this other person is gonna do this thing
because it's the only way that they will
see other person who has passed away
again and it's just like great two
maniacs who can't deal with their grief
and would rather watch the world burn or
kill hundreds of other people are now
gonna fight let's like final fantasy 12
which also had a it didn't have a
straight straight line like some some of
the earlier final fantasies it had lots
of dice diverging plots and mysteries
and like that was less interesting to me
than just kind of this straight up I'm
playing a lot of bravely default now
which feels like a old-school Final
Fantasy game feels like I'm playing
Final Fantasy 6 again it's more that
traditional adventure are right which
you know i'm i'm down with games
experimenting outside of that but also
but you know i don't bravely default
you're enjoying this story there's a
reason that their movies have kind of
three acts that TV shows kind of play
out in three acts because that works
because it's it reminds me of the red
letter media reviews like the blanket
reviews of star wars when they talks
specifically about having a character
when you have a weird world it helps to
have a character that you can identify
with that brick takes you through it and
it helps to have certain things to
ground you in a weird place and that's
one of the things that see I liked final
fantasy 13 because you
I'd lightning but you also had a large
group of people and and the way they
interacted is kind of what got me
through that story like I didn't you
know lightnings you know stoicism was a
thing but you also had that counteracted
by this character in this character they
were always there and lightning wasn't
always there moving ensemble okay yeah
yeah and that's typical that's typical
final fantasy so when you get to
something like 13 on one hand it's good
i'm glad they they wanted a character to
bring you through but i think in this
world it would have been really helpful
to have a more interesting character to
take me through because there's nothing
that makes lightning lightning except
wanting Sarah there is nothing else to
her she has no more to offer and I i
think i would have really loved to have
had a really proper villain to hold on
to because there is no true villain
there is and there isn't in enlightening
research or just a looming threat of
extinction yeah well Ben and eventually
there's a villain that comes out of that
but it's only you know in the last
couple days that it even really starts
to become clear and even then it's more
of just but you don't have that villain
to hold on to and that's why story-wise
I actually liked 13 to the most in the
in the trilogy simply because there was
a villain that I could hold on to a
little bit and it was a sephiroth kind
of villain I think Caius is one of the
great Final Fantasy villains nobody will
remember because he's first of all he's
got a great voice actors the same guy
that voiced the book in near and got the
book guy the book so he's got this great
voice it's a great voice acting voice
and I love listening to Caius talk every
time he opens his mouth but he's got
he's the sephiroth kind of misunderstood
kind of villain as opposed to the kefka
you know I'm insane and that's really
all like you're going to get out of me
villain Caius is a really interesting
villain and I really wish that we had a
better like the entire series it sounds
like it's more of a parable and the real
enemies is our own mortality certainly a
lot of struggling with mortality
although i'd like to see a little bit
more of weirdness from these p
apparently been living in the same state
for 500 years together but the children
have been alive for 500 years not aging
yeah but there's a chance maybe I should
do weird stuff there and interesting
stuff and occasionally they did with tow
to do weird stuff with the 500 year old
yes Justin that's mm-hmm to like get
into some weird psychological stuff
about being young right into this yeah
just get nasty psychologically speaking
uh that turn weird Danny wall it's weird
to be in this game where time has
stopped but time has not stopped now all
at the same time like there's no there's
no real clear rule about how time
actually works in this place to the
class you just go the clocks go and now
they're 12 they used to be 13 and it's
that missing day that's what there is
one interesting thing though about the
story about in the game which is the man
who appears yes but it's also the
religious implication i actually wrote
about this before i wrote the review i
wrote a preview about sort of the jesus
element and and I I was reading
something today about people on GAF
calling lightning basically anime Jesus
and it's very true and it's like those
people have not seen Jesus the animes so
so God is like dealing with religion and
gods and God and fighting gods and stuff
is nothing new in in JRPGs in fact it's
pretty common in JRPGs but in this
particular JRPG this is the most i've
ever seen it go so far as to be so
clearly um an allegory for Christianity
um in very very very obvious ways not
just because lightning is the Saviour
not just because they refer to boo
novella as god with a capital G which
they do yep typically that's not what
happens you don't usually you hear the
gods just referred to as their names
sure this is really interesting to have
and it's it's even though it's a
polytheistic world essentially this is
God at this stage and the collectors
edition does come with a copy of the
Bible they just did a replace all four
kills the thing like the boon of Elza
and essentially the first story quest
you do is all of these women
who are being killed because they look
like lightning all right and so
immediately you have like the story of
Herod killing um all of the all of the
babies so that you can try to kill the
poor children so immediately you have
that kind of allegory but then you get
further and the allegories just keep
getting bigger and bigger and it's kind
of interesting that in games the biggest
to Jesus figures we've had in the last
in the last year or so have been
Elizabeth and snow shock in fact and
Master Chief yes I mean Bioshock I mean
in in bioshock infinite elizabeth is it
is it is it faces way Jesus character
and you know those fishes a daughter in
the form of money and sandwiches the
savage hooker I found a wafer drink this
and remember to me I shouldn't have
brought this up but by the end of the
game and I'm gonna say this without
being spoilery seriously the religious
implications and in some of the ways one
of the characters uses religious II
sounding things too that's usually sound
like comforting things like when you go
to church now they sound really evil and
disturbing and there's some of that in
the very end but it's only the last does
it feel subversive it does feel feel
like reduce maybe maybe I don't know if
the game is that smart um two of two
have really gone fri but I there are
clear links I mean there's definitely a
clear choice to to mirror Christian all
right no you know judeo-christian kind
of religion as opposed to the usual kind
of Japanese mysticism and religious
implications that these games usually
have and so on and so forth so fun aside
from the often overt religious allegory
Cynthia why do you like to play final
fantasy games do you always play final
fantasy games or to have you just where
you just shocked that I had so so I'm
first of all shocked that you had tried
natural we're seeing the way I was
shocked when Danny mentioned that he had
never played a legend of zelda game
before I was like wait what um weird
that's just that's just weird final
fantasy is fine its toll
and why somebody might not get into
Final Fantasy for one reason or another
I stopped playing final fantasy right
around Final Fantasy 10 I didn't like
the leveling system I didn't like the
orbs I didn't like a lot of what you had
to offer my favorite is actually tactics
war of the lions because it's like Game
of Thrones but without like the weird
incest without it incest is what best
that's a problem you know what they say
vice is nice but incest is best and by
they i mean my Latin teacher in high
school about the Romans and it was also
your mother just bring that full circle
yeah that's nope my father is a priest
so we can get into some serious
religious allegory really he's a
minister yeah I had no I gotten that
hurt ya well what what he wasn't when I
was growing nomination he's a
congregational oh fun how did you see
some fantasy I'm pretty sure he has not
played a final fantasy game and doesn't
know much about although he did watch my
brother play final fantasy 7 that was
what sounds like labor returns could be
a family thing you guys play together
cuz your family her has do you have any
family members that play games my mom
tried to play World of Warcraft when I
told her about it many years ago Kevin
what I wait how did that work out right
sadly all my mom and Aiyana hey wall
didn't get into it my mom and I have
played chronicles of narnia games
together when I've gone home and she's
watched me play she watch me play red
dead she watched me play some other cell
but she really likes watching me play
games and she likes watching me like on
the site and reading my stuff even
though she doesn't really understand a
lot of it that's a great mom but she
does play yoville and some others blank
villages I'm in farmville she doesn't
spend any money she actually just goes
in and she I mean she knows that there
are more substantial is yo he'll like a
yogurt themed I think it's one it's just
another farming like yo cows and y 0
Royals story is and I think it's called
royal story is another thing that she
plays because she I'll get things on my
Facebook every so often when she forgets
to turn off notifications or something
and it'll it'll like say I need you know
I need a princess too or something blah
blah blah click those money transactions
didn't ruin my family like that was what
brought my my moment my dad into
bankruptcy
and tough dark dark humor Conan a walls
he supports his entire family on his job
here at game seriously just if I don't
have this job they would all be homeless
on the street he has to go home and make
sure they don't have an internet
connection every Thursday you are the
darkest individual that ever surprised
me coming to gamespot you are pretty
dark sometimes i am from the darkest
timeline yeah I'm gonna bring this to a
close because we all have stuff to do
and and although we could talk about
stuff let's go out of a job we're
certainly gonna be talking more tight
and fall on my [ __ ] wheels and will
probably be talking more final fantasy
13 lightning returns to exile edition I
was thinking I was thinking actually of
doing may be a spoiler cast for Final
Fantasy once you get far enough maybe
get fill color in here and somebody else
that liked the game to come because I
don't want it to be just all we all hate
fantasy lighters and I don't actually
have to be balanced yeah you know I I
just think it's mediocre I think it's a
game at the end of year i will have
forgotten except for the fact that i
played it i will have played it four
times by you and by that man but adds uh
just brutal and i didn't it's not like I
hated it or anything at this stage I can
just whizzed through it and not think
about it as I go so there's there's a
sounds great yeah so well now that it's
a new game plus you know it'll be a new
game plus three so lightning beats me
but I love her she's really not that bad
she's all at least be super overpowered
I five min the stairs look I don't like
the characters but at least I know what
they're gonna say so I just breeze
through it I snippet I skip the cut like
when you skip the cutscenes you actually
realize how little content is in there
and how much of it is just repeating
going out and finding the same monsters
over and over and over again for
chuckling all you find chuckling oh my
goodness every time she opens her mouth
don't you want to just murder her no I
am just I do alright this is somebody
someone was like look I think chocobos
are super insects I need a bangable
chocobo nah buh sexy bird would get me
into some weird HR trouble here at
square enix so I'm gonna make her I'm
gonna take like all human prostitute and
I'm gonna put some wings on her yeah
this better the quest giver let's put
her all over the place when you discover
her backstory it gets if you want to
think about things in those terms when
you actually discover her backs I
haven't actually looked around her
backstory her front story is very
distracting yeah I haven't tightly back
story yet exploring that backstory in
depth oh my god happy Valentine's
related news in related news i'm gonna
bring things to enclose um so first of
all i want to say thank you to diet
barq's once again bring it back around
okay i'll put this this out of yours
down now it says it's good so it must be
oh god no don't touch it don't touch it
alright so there you go but i want to
say thank you to everybody that tuned in
obviously I want you to subscribe to the
podcast we're not just a fun video we
are also a podcast and so you should go
to iTunes and do that whole search for
gamespot gameplay clogging Atta who yeah
and the more you do that the more we can
just keep coming back and to all those
watching us on YouTube for the first
time we're grateful for all of your
incredibly thoughtful and insightful and
respectful comments yeah it's weird so
we appreciate that we know that you love
us and that you would never have
anything negatives to say so it's really
good to be there on YouTube and thank
you to everybody in this room thank you
to Chris waters hey you're welcome Kevin
thanks for watching folks this was fun
hey thank you to just I look forward to
exploring you all in depth thank you
hahaha okay and thank you cynthia
where's for being here as well it's
weird right where's I was worried now
because I've because every so often I'll
get a name wrong and then pretty wrong
it's like and then I'm pretty yeah I
totally miss mispronounced Francis me
mcinnes for the last oh look I can get
that one um but for some reason me shhh
never comes out right yep never get it
quite but thank you to everybody for
joining us you should follow
us on Twitter fiddle Cubs CT waters sly
digital digital Dame and Justin hey
walled and uh we'll see you next time I
guess